et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
lui car vous NAS bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes le
maire d'Alfortville dans le Val-de-Marne
c'est la commune commune en tout cas qui
est proche de L'Haÿ-les-Roses on va en
parler vous êtes le porte-parole du
Parti socialiste et le président de
l'incas l'association qui représente les
centres communaux et intercommunaux
d'actions sociales on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
bonjour Fabrice messerdon bonjour
de l'Est de la France Lucar bounas la
nuit a été beaucoup plus calme dans le
pays pas d'incidents majeurs signalés en
tout cas à l'heure où on se parle est-ce
que pour vous c'est temporaire où on est
à la fin des émeutes un retour à la paix
je n'en sais rien je vois je constate
parce qu'on est tous les merdes
différentes boucles dans nos
associations de des lieux locaux
si on commence à
s'habituer à se dire finalement quelques
voitures brûlées c'est plus calme
qu'elle lui précédente oui on peut faire
ce constat là on peut pas banaliser ce
qui se passe en ce moment moi il y a
trois nuits de cela c'est carrément ma
mérite proximité qui est un équipement
qui abrite aussi la maison française qui
a été incendie alors que nous avons
rendu cet équipement neuf il y a moins
de 2 ans et juste à côté le Marché
Franprix qui a brûlé aussi donc
qu'est-ce que cela renvoie en fait
vis-à-vis des habitants de nos quartiers
que il finit alors que collectivement
tout le monde
condamne ce qui s'est passé pour le
jeune Naël tout le monde est la justice
a fait son travail c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué aux jeunes de ma commune la
justice est passée le policier qui a tué
Naël et au moment où on se parle en
prison et il sera jugé et donc il faut
avoir des mots qui apaisent et des mots
qui qui nomment les choses c'est ce que
nous avons essayé de faire alfold moi je
veux profiter de votre antenne comme
tous les maires pour remercier
fonctionnaires municipaux nos polices
municipales nos policiers nationaux les
pompiers qui depuis 5 nuits sont sur le
terrain c'est compliqué on dort peu hein
on essaye de d'effacer les stigmates de
nuit courte mais en tous les cas nous
sommes là nous sommes présents et moi je
remercie aussi les familles qui ont
entendu notre nos appels le mieux en
particulier pour garder leurs jeux de
mineurs à la maison et je remercie la
jeunesse en général qui comprend que
finalement le gouvernement il y a une
responsabilité des parents il y a une
responsabilité évidente des parents qui
ont des mineurs sont dehors à 23h madame
donc moi je sais pas ce que vos parents
vous disaient mais moi à 23 ans mes
parents me disaient tu es à la maison et
tu dors en fait et oui il y a une
responsabilité des parents au premier au
premier niveau mais il y a un
responsabilité collective et qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire parce que la droite dit
les parents des métiers il faut
suspendre les allocations familiales
est-ce que vous dites la même chose le
discours conservateurs de la droite moi
ce que je dis c'est qu'il faut avoir des
moyens pour nos collectivités à au
moment où nous a supprimé la taxe
d'habitation pour accompagner il y a une
responsabilité vous êtes d'accord pour
le dire mais il doit pas y avoir de
sanction pour vous non mais les parents
aussi pour beaucoup d'entre eux dans les
quartiers dix prioritaires ils sont
esseulés il faut mieux les accompagner
que les réprimer à un moment donné il
faut faire société et le fait de vouloir
stigmatiser des populations en
particulier je pense pas que ce soit la
bonne réponse
il n'y a pas eu d'état d'urgence le
gouvernement a fait le choix force de
l'ordre 40 à 50 000 forces de l'ordre
sur le territoire c'était une bonne
chose de ne pas établir l'état d'urgence
écoutez l'état d'urgence aurait amené
quoi de plus en fait que ce que nous
avons mis en œuvre toutes ces nuits
précédentes moi je faisais pas partie de
ces mères qui auraient et qui réclame
l'état d'urgence de la même manière que
je considère que maire de ma commune ce
n'est pas un maire vous pouvez imaginera
de la ville de prendre des arrêtés de
couvre-feu si couvre-feu il doit y avoir
c'est à la préfecture à l'état de
prendre ses responsabilités de dire à
des populations s'ils doivent rester
chez elle ou non mais pas ou même oui
mais moi ma conception des choses c'est
que ce n'est pas ouvert de prendre des
arrêtés de couvre-feu excusez-moi le
maire n'est pas là pour être liberticide
le maire au contraire il doit être là et
encore plus ces cinq dernières nuits
pour essayer de faire en sorte que les
choses se passent le mieux du monde avec
nos associations dans les quartiers
c'est pas aussi pour protéger une partie
de notre population vous restez chez
vous à partir de telle heure si c'est
pas liberticide je sais pas ce que ça
veut dire une forme de protection de
prendre ses responsabilités c'est pas au
même sur les centres sociaux Fabrice
vouliez poser une question là-dessus oui
vous avez eu des attaques de centre
socio en France oui oui on a eu des CCAS
qui ont été attaqués brûlés nous l'avons
condamné
pas encore mais on fera ce reporting
avec les adhérents de l'Union nationale
des sans-culons en action sociale mais
c'est désolant c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure au début de l'interview
veut dire s'attaquer à des CCAS c'est le
cœur du réacteur même d'une collectivité
on l'a vu avec la crise sanitaire on l'a
vu avec la crise environnementale la
crise climatique énergétique de l'action
sociale ce qui se passe
que descendre que des centres sociaux
soient attaqués il y a aussi des lieux
de vie qui sont à tortues qui sont
brûlés
[Musique]
de la même manière qu'on a beaucoup
qu'on brûle des mairies des mairies de
proximité des médiateurs des CCAS il y a
surtout plus de distinction infinies de
de ce que l'on peut ou ne pas faire et
finalement quand on brûle un service
public c'est brûler notre patrimoine
commun c'est encore plus pour les
populations dites fragiles elles ont
plus que d'autres besoins de nous et de
ces équipements donc c'est un non sens
en amont je comprends pas et je le
évidemment d'une caste nous l'avons
condamné comment à combien vous vous
est-ce que vous arrivez à estimer déjà
un vous le dites il y a eu 5000 émeutes
le coût des dégâts pour votre commune
c'est une bonne question chez poser la
question à mes services vous me
permettrez de pas donner la réponse à
l'antenne j'ai le chiffre parce que je
veux pas rentrer dans une surenchère on
voit bien aujourd'hui avec les réseaux
sociaux qu'on est presque dans un grand
jeu vidéo pour certains jeunes donc je
veux pas prêter le flanc ou nourrir
ce type de de surenchon est-ce que vous
demandez de l'aide à l'état alors nous
allons demander de l'aide surtout
collectivité qui répondent présentes
Valérie Pécresse à la région
Île-de-France a ouvert une enveloppe de
20 millions d'euros pas très collier le
président de la métropole a reporté le
Conseil métropolitain de vendredi
dernier pour les jours à venir il y aura
une délibération là aussi pour
accompagner nos collectivités évidemment
Alfortville déposera des dossiers pour
que nos collectivités de tutelles nous
accompagnent pour réparer ce qui s'est
passé donc pour vous c'est la métropole
à la région de vous aider pas à l'état
voici l'état nous donne de l'argent je
prends mais pour le moment j'ai vous
n'en demandez pas pour le moment j'ai
pas entendu l'état nous proposer quoi
que ce soit en la matière moi tout ce
que je demande à l'état c'est d'arrêter
de venir nous ponctionner par des
charges supplémentaires vous savez
lorsque Monsieur Guérini décide de
manière unilatérale d'augmenter les
fonctionnaires très bien un et demi pour
cent de plus à partir du 1er juillet
mais nous les maires on a voté nos
budget au mois de mars avril et donc
nous impose des charges supplémentaires
alors que nos budgets ont été votés et
c'est cette façon de travailler que le
gouvernement c'est à dire il travaille
sans nous sans les mers sans les
associations des locaux j'ai appris que
le président est réunir 220 maires-vous
que moi qui suis le président des CCAS
de France je suis pas invité donc je
sais pas avec qui il va parler mais en
tous les cas il doit faire vraiment
choisir ses invités
là il est rose dans le domicile a fait
l'objet d'une attaque comment vous le
connaissez j'imagine bien sûr pas très
loin en plus comment vous réagissez à ce
qui s'est passé comme tout le monde
c'est consternant
imaginez-vous ce qu'a subi sa femme et
ses enfants à 1h30 du matin sa femme a
été blessée et ses enfants se réveillent
parce que leur maison est incendie avec
un véhicule projeté on est dans autre
chose évidemment que l'on condamne que
l'on est aux côtés de Vincent Jean Brun
et de sa famille mais on a franchi un
nouveau cap tout le monde le dit le
reconnaît mais une fois qu'on a dit ça
vous savez
Vincent Jean Brun et moi nous étions
avec tous les mers vendredi soir à un
zoom organisé par Madame la préfète du
Val-de-Marne le procureur le directeur
territorial de la sécurité publique
Vincent Jean Brun fait partie de ses
mères qui lors de ce zoom à interpellé
les représentants de l'État en disant on
a un problème j'ai un problème avec ma
police municipale qui n'a plus assez de
cartouches de flash-ball le maire de
Villejuif ce soir là a pris la parole
pour dire qu'il avait exiltré sa famille
parce que menacé lui aussi le maire de
Bonneuil-sur-Marne ce soir-là a dit la
même chose malheureusement pour Vincent
Jobin et sa famille ça s'est concrétisé
nous les maires nous sommes extrêmement
exposés désormais on sait où on vit
certains disaient on est apporté de
baffes aujourd'hui on est apporté de
coups et parfois à porter de couple qui
peuvent être mortels et donc pour le
coup j'appelle l'État à nous donner à
nous les merdes les moyens de pouvoir
accomplir nos fonctions on me dit de
l'État vous protège pas suffisamment
vous les maires en tous les cas la
justice n'a pas assez de moyens pour que
la loi soit appliquée moi le premier
lorsque les avaient de dire
passer vous ne croyez pas non je crois
pas j'y crois pas d'ailleurs samedi
après-midi vous l'avez peut-être vu j'ai
répondu à une interview chez vos
collègues du Nouvel Obs si je disais
nous nous sentons abandonnés et c'est le
sentiment de tous les maires de France
parce que une fois que la première
ministre et c'est ministre sont venus et
c'est bien qu'ils soient venus c'est
normal que les représentants du
gouvernement soient aux côtés de Vincent
Jean Brun et de sa famille dans ces
cas-là mais une fois qu'ils ont dit ce
qu'ils ont été amenés à dire qu'est-ce
qui se passe de plus est-ce qu'on a plus
de policiers est-ce qu'on a plus de
moyens vous demandez quoi plus de
policiers municipaux plus de moyens pour
vos paniers
de l'argent en fait je l'état
aujourd'hui depuis pendant 6 ans ne
cesse de ponctionner sur nos budgets de
fonctionnement pour nous empêcher de
faire notre travail comme il se doit
parce qu'ils n'ont aucune aucune
conscience de ce qu'est le métier de
maire en fait et de ses réalités
aujourd'hui c'est pas leur matière j'ai
rencontré comme président Lucas
Dominique Faure il y a un Manon 10 jours
au ministère à Beauvau elle nous a dit
que
la mésicule du territoriale elle nous a
dit que se préparer une loi pour le mois
de novembre prochain où on nous
donnerait peut-être plus de moyens et un
arsenal juridique renforcé dont axes moi
je vais pas faire de procès d'intention
j'attends de voir ce qu'on va nous
proposer du carbonara si vous avez pas
le passé déjà fait l'objet de menace de
mort bien sûr on a plusieurs fois deux
trois quatre fois quatre fois quatre
fois il y a eu des anciens judiciaires
il y a toujours alors moi je reconnais à
la justice qu'elle a toujours fait son
travail lorsque j'ai déposé plainte la
justice a fait son travail la préfète du
Val-de-Marne a fait plus que son travail
au moment où je vous il y a une personne
aujourd'hui qui est censée être connu
comme déficiente mentalement et qui à
l'asile dans un asile psychiatrique
cette personne a été arrêtée 4 fois 4
fois dans ma commune avec un couteau
dans chaque main en hurlant qu'elle
allait me tuer c'est Madame la préfète
qui a pris un arrêté d'internement pour
que demain il ne sortent pas sans son
accord donc oui les responsables de
l'État sont à nos côtés quand nous
sommes en grande difficulté et il faut
le reconnaître oui pour en revenir aux
événements du week-end et surtout aux
positions politiques Éric Ciotti ce
weekend estimait que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est devenu un danger pour la République
par les propos qu'il tient notamment à
l'égard de la police ce que vous
partagez cette analyse moi je jetterai
pas d'un atome de cette manière là
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a été trois fois je
crois qu'on est dans l'élection
présidentielle erikiotti 0 fois donc à
chacun son CV par contre non c'est pas
ça le curseur c'est qu'à un moment donné
on peut pas dire d'un homme politique
qui est un danger
les mots du sens
de la part de Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
qu'il n'est pas appelé au calme il
aurait dû au contraire dans son rôle de
responsable politique est très clair là
aussi dans les mots et il ne l'a pas
fait d'autres de ses amis l'ont fait
plus clairement donc il faut aussi le
reconnaître mais aujourd'hui la grande
expliqué Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'est pas
fait ben vous lui poserez la question de
la même manière que j'ai vu un tweet
très minimaliste avec une empathie
mesurée vis-à-vis de Vincent Jean Brun
et de sa famille hier matin je ne sais
pas mais en tous les cas moi je crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit clair et aux
parties socialiste je supporte parole du
Parti socialiste nous avons été avec
Olivier Faure très clair sur l'appel au
calme et à la responsabilité de chacun
mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous dites il
n'est pas clair est-ce que du coup
il n'a pas appelé au calme donc c'est
très clair ce que je dis on me parle de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui aujourd'hui n'a
aucune respons en réalité politique je
vois bien pour arriver à gagner
le Parti socialiste aussi une voix qui
porte à gauche et je pense que c'est
cette voix là qui a été entendue pendant
8 ans se détacher clairement que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Parti socialiste
c'est quoi le sujet là c'est encore
amené sur la nuesse pas l'alliance à
gauche la nuit Pesse c'est quoi c'est
l'union de la gauche c'est
l'alliance sur des causes communes et on
l'a vu sur les retraites très clairement
donc moi je tiens à cette alliance tout
en disant clairement les choses quand
certains membres de la nuit Pesse ne
font ne sont pas claires sur les propos
qu'ils doivent avoir mais quand hier
soir sur LCI par exemple Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il parle d'une maltraitance
policière systématique à l'égard de
certaines populations qu'est-ce que vous
dites de ça je suis pas d'accord du tout
avec lui voilà que après il y ait au
sortir de des écoles de police des
fonctions de police
moins bien formé aujourd'hui qu'hier
c'est forcément possible et parce que là
aussi c'est institution a moins de
moyens aujourd'hui qui est donc il faut
certainement mieux former nos policiers
mieux les valoriser mieux les payer mais
surtout une République sans sa police ce
n'est pas la République et moi je suis
plutôt un maire proche de sa police et
je crois que je suis reconnu comme tel
et j'irai jamais là aussi jeter des
anathèmes sur ceux qui sont les
détenteurs
que certains policiers tuent comme ça a
été le cas pour le jeune à elle oui il
faut le dire c'est ce que j'ai dit moi
très clairement mais la police elle tue
pas la police elle nous protège il faut
clairement le dire vous êtes d'accord
vous êtes vraiment sur un des accords de
fond en termes de valeurs là
je sais pas si on les sur un désaccord
de fond d'autant que quand j'entends
encore une fois les responsables de la
France insoumise beaucoup et c'est eux
qu'il faudrait interroger plus que moi
moi je peux parler pour elle les fiches
je suis membre du Parti socialiste
beaucoup sont des solidarisés
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et son et ses
propos il faudrait qu'ils prennent du
recul qu'ils parlent moins Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je crois que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon regrette une chose c'est de ne
pas avoir été à nouveau député et
cherche le buzz à chaque fois qu'il le
peut je pense que ce n'est pas la bonne
façon de faire voilà de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier politique une cagnotte a été
lancée en ligne à la faveur du politique
et auteur du tir contre le jeune Naël
800.000 euros ont déjà été collectés ce
matin est-ce que selon vous il faut
arrêter cette cagnotte est-ce qu'il faut
l'interdire je crois que cette cagnotte
a été lancé par c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit de l'autre côté
pour ces appétences d'extrême droite
d'ailleurs soutenu Éric Zemmour l'année
dernière présidentielle voilà qu'est-ce
que je vous dise de plus
il vaudrait mieux que
l'opérateur qui l'héberge ferme cette
cagnotte pour revenir à la France
insoumise et à la police la France
insoumise va déposer une proposition de
loi pour abroger l'article qui régit les
tirs des policiers et la légitime
défense Jean-Luc Mélenchon dit que cette
loi qui est une association
qui était portée quand Bernard Cazeneuve
était premier ministre c'est un permis
de tuer quand dites-vous et ça n'existe
pas les permis de tuer là aussi les mots
du sens que l'on fasse avec un peu de
recul un reporting sur la loi de 2017
puisqu'il s'agit de cela très bien qu'on
évalue très clairement et concrètement
ce qui s'est produit depuis 2017 mais là
aussi
sortir des expressions
de cette manière là je pense que je
pense que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est à côté
de la plaque je vous le dis que très
clairement il est à côté de la plaque et
alors c'est normal il a jamais été mère
donc il ne saisit pas à l'instant
présent ce que l'on concitoyens
attendent des élus
en général et donc heureusement
heureusement que la grande majorité de
ses amis ne sont ne vont pas dans son
sens donc il faut pas abroger cette loi
cet article c'est pas ce que j'ai dit
j'ai dit je suis tout à fait favorable à
ce que il y est une analyse depuis 2017
ou cet article a été voté voir ce qui
s'est produit est-ce que oui ou non ça a
laissé entendre que des policiers ont
peut-être utilisé plus facilement leur
arme ou pas moi je suis pas policier
j'en sais rien en fait donc il se pose
un problème politique regardons-le de
manière factuelle passe d'armes ce
week-end entre le maire écologiste de
Lyon Grégory Doucet et ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin qui reproche
à la ville de Lyon d'avoir retiré des
policiers municipaux et d'éviter
camionnettes des caméras de
vidéosurveillance il y a forte ou pas
alors j'ai pas suivi du tout cette passe
d'armes pardonnez-moi parce que j'étais
plus préoccupé de ce qui se passait dans
ma commune que des échanges entre le
ministre de l'Intérieur le maire de Lyon
c'est sûr que d'une collectivité à
l'autre vous n'aurez pas les mêmes
politiques publiques en matière de
police municipale voilà je pense que
Monsieur Doucet les caméras de
vidéosurveillance
mais j'en mets et je continue en mettre
c'est de la vidéo protection pas de la
vidéo surveillance et heureusement qu'on
avait notre centre de surveillance sur
pain notre CSU oui mais moi je suis pas
pour cette gauche timoré sur les
questions de sécurité moi j'ai toujours
été très clair j'ai mis en place une
police municipale en 2016 qui est armé
qui a des caméras piétons j'ai mis en
place un CSU un centre de surveillance
urbain qui a montré toutes ces qualités
pendant ces cinq dernières nuits puisque
ça participait à la coordination des
deux polices nationales et municipales
voilà je crois que on a changé de
paradigme vous savez ces dernières les
questions dites régalienne portées par
l'État sur le logement sur la sécurité
maintenant avec la covid sur la santé
publique ont été renvoyés aux
collectivités territoriales c'est comme
ça je dis pas que c'est normal parce que
ça nous demande plus de moyens mais
aujourd'hui là aussi sur tous ces sujets
que je viens de citer ce sont les mères
qui sont en première ligne une dernière
question le plus politique on parlait de
Bernard cazen tout à l'heure à l'époque
où il était premier ministre aujourd'hui
il a lancé son mouvement est-ce que pour
vous il peut incarner l'avenir de la
gauche l'avenir du PS en tous les cas
c'est un homme de gauche avec qui il
faudra qu'on discute est-ce qu'il peut
incarner l'alternance je ne le crois pas
voilà et puis je me souviens de Bernard
Cazeneuve qui a été très très violent
vis-à-vis de nous les socialistes chez
vos confrères de France Inter il y a
quelques semaines on nous pointant du
doigt sur notre inaction lors de la
campagne présidentielle de Anne
hidalgoop vous savez on avait installé
Bernard cadavre président du comité de
soutien de Anne Hidalgo le samedi le
lundi je devais l'avoir au téléphone
pour organiser la remontée des
signatures vous savez ce qu'il m'a dit
il me dit je vais te dire cher Luke ce
que j'ai dit Anne j'ai accepté le poste
mais je ferais rien parce que j'ai pas
le temps et on a fait 1,7 donc monsieur
Cazeneuve qui donne des leçons à tout le
monde moi j'ai décidé aujourd'hui de de
dire les choses là aussi et qu'à un
moment donné on peut pas
penser être un espoir quand au moment où
on a eu le plus besoin de vous vous
n'avez rien fait donc il est discrédité
Ops
donc son mouvement de manarien pour vous
c'est une impasse c'est un mouvement de
gauche en plus du reste mais qui offre
une ligne politique qui a échoué en fait
et je pense que les nos concitoyens
n'attendent pas de rejouer le même
la même séquence que 2012-2017 ou un
président n'a même pas pu se représenter
à sa propre réélection
et c'est même ligne portée par d'autres
portées par Carole Delga par exemple
est-ce qu'elle pourrait vous convenir
moi j'ai qu'une ligne celle du Parti
socialiste quand on investit des
candidats on est derrière les candidats
investis par le Parti socialiste si on
lance pas des candidatures dissidentes
ou alors on est en dehors des clous et
que quel que soit les personnalités qui
espèrent demain être candidates ou
candidat à l'élection présidentielle ils
auront besoin du Parti socialiste qu'il
m'amène un peu souvent à mon goût en ce
moment un dernier mot le carbonate
puisqu'on apprend à l'instant avec un
tweet de Gérald Darmanin que cette nuit
on luttant contre un feu de plusieurs
véhicules dans un parking souterrain
Saint-Denis un pompier de 24 ans et
décédé quel est votre réaction pas plus
tard que ce matin j'ai envoyé un SMS à
mon adjudant responsable de la caserne
d'Alfortville Maisons-Alfort pour le
remercier de ce que les pompiers
faisaient toutes les nuits ce matin
juste avant d'arriver sur votre plateau
c'est un drame et je pense évidemment à
la famille de ce sapeur-pompier vous
savez ce sont les soldats du feu sauver
ou périr c'est leur devise bah c'est
dramatique merci Lucas merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin merci
Fabrice on continue évidemment à parler
de ces sujets tout de suite dans le
cadre des territoires